hold onto your dragons and kiss your
nephew oh god I can't believe I just
said that because after over a year and
a half we had the most thrilling thing
to happen to a royal family since Prince
Harry introduced the Queen to memes but
before we get into the episode we need
to talk about the opening credits
because I believe they offer substantial
clues as to how this season will develop
and the best way to do that is to
compare these credits with previous
seasons for example the season 7 opening
credits predominantly featured six
locations King's Landing Dragonstone
Winterfell the wall east watch and old
town while season 8 only features for
the wall last hearth Winterfell and
King's Landing
this leads me to believe and I think
it's quite obvious that season 8 will
focus mainly in the north and in King's
Landing we first see the wall which has
been updated since its attacked by the
night King to show its destruction as we
progress further south and Westeros that
tiles turn blue signifying the knight
king's ever-increasing hold over the
region we then turn to last hearth than
northernmost settlement in the north
which is currently run by Ned umber the
grandson of Greatjon umber who fought
alongside Robb Stark in season two it's
revealed in season six that great John
has passed away
and Ned umber here takes control of the
house I'm getting a little ahead of
myself here but it's last heart that
tormund beric Dondarrion and Edison
tallit find abandoned near the end of
the episode it's Ned Amber's corpse they
find attached to the wall surrounded by
limbs forming a mysterious white Walker
symbol and I'll talk about that a little
bit later on in the video as Ned awakens
as a white he's quickly burned by
barrack and god damn I love that flaming
sword we then continue on to Winterfell
where I believe most of the season will
take place it's been a pretty
well-established rumor that a 55-day
knight shoot in freezing cold
temperatures was shot with almost all of
the characters being featured in it and
my best guess is that this refers to
Winterfell since all the characters seem
to be congregating there we also get
this really interesting signet which
shows several of the house animals on
the Left we have a lion eating a fish
which could mean a Lannister killing a
Tully the middle a direwolf being hung
a stark and on the right a white Walker
holding a lion head signifying a
Lannister to me this is the most
substantial clue we get from the
introductory credits and I want to hear
your thoughts below in the comments we
then get King's Landing which i think is
just there because Circe's storyline
will take place there and then we get
this symbol of House Lannister
overlooking the throne my guess is
that's because the current ruler is a
Lannister but look at the shot that
follows right after it's a dragon
signifying Targaryen could this mean
Daenerys or perhaps Jon Snow now knowing
that he's a Targaryen could sit on the
throne I literally could talk for hours
just about this intro but we have a
whole episode to get into by the way if
you're liking the video so far please
give it a like share and comment now
let's get into the real meat of things
we open on a young boy traveling through
the outskirts of Winterfell to see the
unsullied arrive for Winterfell this is
a huge culture shock not only have they
likely never seen foreigners from the
continent of Essos but there are two
giant friggin dragons which haven't been
seen for centuries especially in the
north behind the unsullied you can make
it a few Dothraki as well and damn girl
look at Danny rocking that white fur
coat with shoulder pads wait until John
finds out that cheese is an awkward Arya
watches on proud she hasn't seen John
since season one but that short lived as
one of the men on her list to kill
Sandor Clegane aka the hound arrives as
well he's followed by Gendry who he
previously believed to be the true heir
to the crown being the son of Robert
Baratheon
but since Dany and John are there he's
way down the list and riding in luxury
is our pal Tyrion Lannister alongside
Lord Varys behind him his green worm and
his lover miss and I this whole section
is a cavalcade of known characters
finally converging in one place the
crowd then sees Danny's dragons in a
mixture of fear and awe then more
reunions Jon sees bran for the first
time since season 1 he does not yet know
he's turned into the three-eyed Raven
John says bran is almost a man which
bran replies almost that line itself
says so much it's not about him being an
adult it's about him almost not being a
human he's instilled with the powers of
the three-eyed Raven Queen Danny is
introduced to
Ansah the lady of Winterfell who's as
stone cold in meeting her as Winterfell
itself then bran has to rain on
everyone's parade by cutting through all
the [ __ ] in explaining the current
situation the night king has taken one
of Danny's dragons and has already
broken through the wall we then have
Sansa calling on Lord Ned umber for his
troops who needs more supplies in order
to get his men south and time remember
Ned umbers the lad who unfortunately
finds himself pinned to the walls of
last hearth we also have fan favorite
Lee and a Mormon who's like WTF John are
you not our leader now like why is Queen
Elsa over here taken over and honestly
John is quite rational here they brought
dragons and men even joined with the
Lannisters because if they don't they're
all gonna die at the hands of the night
king Gendry here is preparing wagons of
coal and we'll see later on this coolers
needed to Forge the dragon glass to
supply the army with weapons to take on
the army of the Dead and look at this a
husband-and-wife reunion yes they
haven't spoken since Joffrey's wedding
in season 4 and Tyrion is pretty cryptic
with Sansa telling her that Cersei quote
now has something to live for
he's referring of course to her baby but
Sansa walks away saying I used to think
you're the cleverest man alive perhaps a
jab that Cersei may not be pregnant at
all and that Tyrion fell for it and then
look at bran being such a creeper and
then we get that Arya John reunion we've
all been waiting for
she still has the Valyrian steel needle
that Jon gave her as a gift all the way
back in season one he's in like [ __ ]
you seen this and pulls out an even
bigger blade made out of Valyrian and
judging how this combo goes it's clear
Jon and Arya still love each other but
Arya still isn't sold on him bending the
knee to Danny
she doesn't want his love for Dany
clouding the fact that Sansa and her our
family she ends the scene saying we're
family don't forget that back in King's
Landing Qyburn tells Cersei the dead
have broken through the wall and Circe's
like and then we get our first glimpse
at the gold company a group of
mercenaries from Essos into the command
of harry strickland
he's being brought to Westeros using
euron greyjoy ships and below deck we
get a loving uncle nice chat with urine
in his captive Yara he's not gonna kill
her just yet back in King's Landing
Cersei is holding a tantrum because
the golden company hasn't brought the
war elephants they're renowned for your
on however has only one thing on his
mind he's become frustrated he's done so
much and has gotten nothing in return
and he's suffering from tremendous blue
balls
[Music]
someone should introduce him to Ramsay
Bolton then sir cease like Paul Wright
pity speaking of bran seems to be having
a terrible time and look at this Walker
you just got Kai burned seems Cersei
wants a word with our man she wants
Bronn to kill Tyrion and Jaime in the
event the armies defeat the White
Walkers not only that she wants to kill
them with a crossbow the same weapon
Tyrion used to kill their father Tywin
my guess is that bran will not go
through with killing Jaime or Tyrion one
he's already established friendships
with both of them and to his character
arc would work out so much better if he
didn't do it for the entire series bran
has been nothing but women and money
putting himself before all others to see
him change and for once choose somebody
else over himself would be a great turn
for his character and I think overall
satisfying for G ot fans
then again Game of Thrones is known for
throwing everything on its head and
Cersei just got the D but can't stop
thinking about elephants urine also does
this weird belly rub saying he's going
to put a prince in her belly apparently
she hasn't told them there's a bun in
the oven
unless of course that's a lie and look
who it is Theon Greyjoy saves his sister
and okay maybe not the Welcome you were
anticipating but he did abandon her and
jump ship last season Yara tells Theon
that with urines men in King's Landing
they can reclaim the Iron Islands after
all if the defense of the North fails
Dany will need someplace to retreat to
someplace the dead can't go but Theon
and his heart wants to go to Winterfell
he wants to redeem all the wrongdoings
he has done and this may mean he may die
doing so that may be the only way he can
fully right his wrongs and Davos as a
quick talk with Tyrion about the men of
the North how Dany the Dothraki and
unsullied
will need to prove themselves to gain
their trust and he proposes that the
seven kingdoms should they survive the
incoming invasion be ruled by a just
woman and an honorable man both Dany and
John on the throne but it's various who
has the last line
that nothing lasts as we look upon Danny
and John looking lovingly at each other
perhaps foreshadowing that one of them
will make it till the end of the season
and Danny is all emo because Sansa
doesn't like her she's the queen and
wants some damn respect all I'm saying
is my nerves are bad I've been on
medication and everything I just respect
the dothraki arrived and Danny is
concerned the dragons are barely eating
but hey they're strong enough to go on a
magical dragon riding date I can show
you and they share a hot passionate kiss
in front of a waterfall with these two
perverts watching especially this one
Gendry is busy making blades at a dragon
glass for the Hound who has a sweet new
axe and the loving reunions continue
with Aria and click aim aria also meets
up with Gendry who she last saw in
season 2 she hands him a special design
for a blade made of dragonglass and this
is super important notice how the tip
can come apart from the hilt we'll
definitely be seeing this in action and
was it just me or was there a little
thing going on between these two
who Lala and John is getting more [ __ ]
from Sansa that he bent the knee when
will these people understand there's a
friggin army of the dead on their
doorstep you want to worry about who
holds what title I'm telling you it
doesn't matter and that's all that
really matters at the end of the day and
sense it goes in for the kill here did
you bend the need to save the nose well
because you love her Danny and captain
friend zone over here thanks Sam for
healing Jorah and offers him a reward he
just wants a pardon for borrowing some
books nerd oh yeah he also stole a
Valyrian sword from his father who oh
this is awkward she killed his dad and
brother and as Sam goes to get some
fresh air bran is doing his creepy
watching again he's apparently waiting
for an old friend my guess is that he's
actually referring to Jaime Lannister of
whom he shares another creepy stare off
later on in the episode it was Jaime
fool remember who threw him off the
tower after he caught him having naughty
time with his sister either way he tells
Sam it's time for him to tell Jon about
his real heritage in the crypts below
Winterfell were the dead of House Stark
lay Sam and Jon reunite and cats out of
the bag Sam tells Jon he's the son of
Rhaegar
garyun in Lyanna Stark making him the
rightful heir to the throne his real
name is Aegon Targaryen if you want to
know more about the family tree and how
this all works out I'm putting a link in
the description to a video by useful
charts which Maps it all out and here we
are at last hearth the place we saw in
the introductory credits and where Ned
umber said he couldn't get his men to
Winterfell in time well it looks like
they met a pretty gruesome fate as the
night king and his men have already
arrived here tormund beric Dondarrion
and edison tolet uncover the body of ned
number which Barrack says is a message
from the night king torment says they
need to get to Winterfell ASAP and my
guess is that they will or just as the
fight is ending in time to save some of
our heroes in their time of need
now it may just be me but the formation
here looks a lot like the sigil for
House Targaryen but beyond that who
knows what the real message the knight
King is trying to say but if the rumors
are true that the night King and House
Targaryen are somehow related this could
be some crazy foreshadowing and look who
it is our favorite one-armed sister
lover and he's pretty shocked to see
brand my guess is in future episodes
these two will talk the three-eyed Raven
sees all and with Bronn potentially
coming to kill him and who knows what
his sister is up to bran will surely
come in handy that's it for this episode
guys I literally have no idea how this
video will do since I'm up against a
thousand other Game of Thrones videos so
every like comment and share is such a
huge help to me I'm hoping to break down
every episode and hope you'll watch with
me along the way if you want to ask me
any questions you can reach me on
twitter at think story whitey winter is
finally here
so remember daddy loves you very much